Welcome!
Master!
Lady!
Hello!
Hi guys!
Hi!
Where are we walking?
I've just been looking at this...
At this menu and just kind of like taking in...
Like look!
That's actual Surugaia!
An actual maid dreaming!
Oh my gosh, family stop.
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
How are you doing Mint?
I'm good!
How are you guys?
How are you?
Welcome to Mint Cafe on Electric Street!
Ohayo!
And look!
It's Magi... Magi... Magi...
Definitely not Mado Magi.
It's Magi...
Mado... Magi... Magi Mugu.
Yeah, I'm really excited to play this.
I don't really quite know much of anything about it.
Except that we're running a maid cafe.
And that's like my thing.
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Seems like the wrong time of year for Sakura Blooms.
It's okay.
We are in spring.
It's to warm us up a little bit.
Since it's cold weather now, right?
Welcome!
Thanks for three months!
I hope I said your name right.
Extremely busy moving apartments.
Oh no!
Paperbacks!
Oh gosh, moving is such a hassle.
J-Rag!
Thanks for the donation!
Thank you!
Yeah, we have Woe Donalds.
And Softmap.
Fun.
It's funny, I had a lot of people being like...
Mint needs to play this game.
Like, you are...
You are maid cafe in Akihabara.
You must play.
But, I must actually you.
I must put on my nerd glasses and...
Actually...
Actually, this is not Akihabara.
In fact, this is Nihonbashi.
In Osaka.
And actually, I've never been before.
It's kind of like...
Called the Akihabara of Osaka.
Kind of.
But I've never been before, so...
I've actually never been to Osaka.
So, actually...
This is not Akihabara.
So you will not have me being like...
This place I recognized.
But maybe...
Maybe sometime when I go to Japan and I have time...
And I can go to Osaka.
Maybe then I can have a reverse situation.
You know, like for some people that watch my streams and are just like...
Oh, Minto talked about this place.
And then I went to Akihabara and I saw it.
That would be me.
I'll see it in this game.
And then I'll go to Akihabara...
Not Akihabara, Nihonbashi and I'll be like...
I recognize this from...
From Mint Cafe on Electric Street.
It's kind of a...
Maybe a rare opportunity for me.
Since I've been to Japan so many times.
So...
But I've never had a chance to make it over to Osaka.
I can't wait for my mint merch to arrive.
Thanks.
Thank you!
The moment I saw this game I thought of you.
I've been playing it myself.
It's very cute and fun!
I think you'll really love it.
Wow, thank you!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...
Actually...
Playism sent me a code for this.
It's not sponsored.
In fact, I got the game from a friend.
But...
And then I saw that they had sent me a code.
So...
I will still thank them for the code.
But...
Do we get a free pass to eat the Minky plushies?
Of course!
Please.
Oh my gosh.
I saw like the Ronald...
Sorry, the...
McWonald.
The Wonald McWonald.
He was so freaky.
But yeah!
So...
I guess let's just start the game.
It's kind of fun.
Wow.
Electric Street Rumors.
Doing part-time job...
Oh.
Employee number 996.
Something.
That's a Metal Gear reference.
Oh my god, my boss.
I can't read how long you spent in the bathroom.
4 minutes and 3 seconds.
Oh gosh.
It's one of those places.
That's me.
This guy right here.
I believe you are aware of the 3 minute rule in the employee manual.
Have you guys ever had a job like that?
I had a job once.
Where my boss, she would...
She would count how many minutes I was in the bathroom.
And also, if I laughed too loud, she would yell at me.
Thankfully, no.
Oh, you're so lucky.
You're so lucky.
It says clearly, 3 bathroom breaks a day, 3 minutes each.
But you don't seem to be following the rules.
I'm sure you're aware that the company has never been late with your salary payments.
I'm not one to buy merch ever, but I had to get the cheeky sticker.
It made me smile to see a side of you we don't see very often.
I appreciate...
I think that's very funny.
I'm glad...
I'm glad you liked it.
Nihonbashi is nicer to shop in.
Actually, the prices are generally lower than Akiba.
No speaking ill of Akiba in any way in this premises.
Listening from the bathroom at work.
Went to Osaka Nihonbashi back in March this year.
Feels more intimate than Akiba.
Less big streets.
I recommend visiting Racing Bar 100R.
I also have to go because that's where the other snake is.
Because he's at the other...
Super Potato.
There's the snake in the Super Potato in Akiba on the third floor.
I visit him every time.
And then there's the snake...
There's a big old snake...
Statue outside of the Super Potato in Osaka.
You have to kiss both snakes.
I will be...
Deported.
Can I deport a ghost?
I'll just...
Possess somebody.
And then...
That person can...
Get deported maybe.
Worth it.
I don't want Super Potato to close.
But the day that they do...
You know I will be in there saying...
Hey!
You selling that guy?
Hey...
You wanna auction off?
I would win.
If there's an auction...
You guys, I'm sorry.
You will know where your donors go to.
I'm so sorry.
I will buy another plane ticket.
For him to sit with me on the plane.
We expected of you.
I'm saving up my money for that moment.
Every minto plushie you buy goes towards the snake retirement fund.
In my house.
The transparency is appreciated of course.
But how about you?
You can't even follow the simplest of rules.
Therefore your salary for today will be deducted from your paycheck this month.
I'll be keeping an eye on you, punk.
I really hope there won't be a next time.
But if there is...
That will be the end of your time here.
Got it?
This place doesn't even...
They don't even have windows.
Snake fund.
Trash boat.
And Mango the cat.
Thank you.
That reminds me.
There's an urgent assignment for you.
I want to see it done by the end of the day.
Oh, the day.
Now back to your desk and get to work.
Number 996.
Okay.
Have you guys ever seen those like places...
They have like...
They create giant skylight looking lights.
Like light panels for apartments and office buildings that don't have actual windows.
It just feels even more...
I don't want to say dystopian.
But it just feels, you know.
Baby Cori, thanks for the gift.
Movement.
Okay.
Confirm with the Z.
Oh, interact.
Was it Z or A?
Cancel with X.
Oh, I can just leave?
I can't take it anymore.
Oh my god, employee 997.
Sorry, my head is blocking the names a little bit.
I might have to move or...
Maybe I'll shrink the screen a little bit.
I never bought an opi mousepad until last time.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Super Ray, thanks for 5 months.
My head is gonna explode.
He is dead now?
The guy next to me hasn't moved a muscle for hours.
Oh god.
He must be exhausted from the boss chewing him out.
But still...
Is he...
Alive?
I sure hope so.
Oh my god, employee 404.
Oh no.
This was employee 985.
Let's see.
Oh, employee 811648.
I wonder if there is any...
Like, you know how with numbers you can make...
Like, words in Japanese.
And 404 seems like a joke.
404, yeah, fatal error.
But I wonder what 811648 is.
I'm not very good at, like, the...
Not leet-speak.
Yes, I watched that Conan episode.
It's not even...
Yeah, the Goro Awase.
It's not even just a Conan thing.
But I did watch that episode too.
Because it's really...
I think of it all the time because it's really funny.
Prisoner 24609.
I'm going to eat the plushie.
Do it.
Fill it with chili.
Yeah.
811...
I don't know.
I'm not good at them at all.
Damn it.
I think this place is a black company.
I have a sneaking suspicion.
Employee 807.
Hello, honey?
I'm still at the office.
Yes, I know.
But...
Can?
I think.
Can we talk about our date after work?
I know, I know.
If I can get even a single day off this week, I promise I'll spend it with you.
Okay?
I won't stand you up this time.
I promise.
Please, believe in me.
Just this once.
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Oh my god!
No!
This guy!
Oh wait, that's Kan...
That's not O.
That's Kan...
I don't know.
I don't know the kanji.
Kan something.
Minto would be employee 310.
Yes, I would.
It's all...
Oh no!
This guy.
This poor guy.
Hey, are you alright?
Oh, this is employee 711.
That guy counted the exact number of times I went to the vending machine.
What is he?
A stalker or something?
Besides, is that his whole job?
Just to monitor us all day?
Does that mean I'll do that if I get promoted in the future?
By the way, I've been using a dating app while he's not looking.
But I just realized that I have absolutely no time to go on dates.
Because of this stupid job.
And I'm paying for that app the whole time.
I just really want a girlfriend, man.
But I don't have time.
This is so sad.
If you want to know how long someone's been in the company, here's a pro tip.
The bolder they are, the longer their time here.
99% accuracy.
Everyone here is looking pretty...
Even us.
Look, we're kind of...
We look like Araragi-kun.
We're the main character.
Oh, Yuki.
Did you just get an urgent assignment?
Tough luck, dude.
Looks like you'll be here all night again.
Listen, here's some advice from your senior.
Slack off when he's not looking.
If you can't do that, you won't last long.
Neither physically nor mentally.
Now get back to work before he starts complaining again.
No!
I'm a free spirit.
Also, I see we have a...
We have nothing in our bag.
What if I just leave?
You should go back to work.
Back and work at your desk.
Back to work.
I feel like I'm watching a horror game.
He's not looking.
I'm slacking.
Finally, he's gone.
Start standing at the door right around the end of the workday.
Every day!
Oh, Yuki is about to lose it.
So that he can make sure you clock out first.
And then go back to work.
That's...
That's what?
It's 21 PM.
I know, right?
21 o'clock.
What is that?
9?
Oh, right.
Wanna grab a drink later?
What?
You still have work?
Come on.
We can both tell it's not something you can finish in a day.
That assignment is pretty much meaningless anyway.
He's just trying to get under your skin.
You're not going?
Sure.
But you don't look so good.
I'll be off, but you be careful, okay?
Are we gonna get Isekai to...
Maid Cafe World?
I finally finished my work for today.
Press confirm at the door to leave the office.
Oh, we're not the only one left here.
Observe?
What is this?
Work's over.
You should go back to your dorm room.
A dorm room?
Am I a student?
Employee 404 is fucking dead.
Oh, you're leaving?
Okay, see you tomorrow.
Wait, no.
See you today, I guess.
It's 1 AM!
I'll be sleeping here tonight.
If I go home, I'd have no time to sleep at all.
Off you go.
Rest whenever you can.
Got it?
What is this?
The death march or something?
This is why maid cafes are so...
Oh my gosh, it's raining.
We don't even have an umbrella.
Hello, can this diamond dog get a birthday salad from VTubers?
Yes, gross hair!
I thought it was Hotaru no Hikari for a second.
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
Happy birthday with salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Gross hair!
Happy birthday!
The music is so sweet.
You drag your exhausted body out of the office...
only to realize that it's raining heavily outside.
Good thing I brought an umbrella.
I did bring an umbrella.
You open your umbrella and walk against the wind.
The streets are eerily empty in the middle of the night.
A strong wind drained your stamina.
The second your concentration wanes, your umbrella is whipped out of your hands.
Losing your balance and being unable to see clearly through the rain, you trip on something and fall over.
I like these movies, how you have Kill Bill and then the girl who...
Oh wait, my head is blocking it!
Here, hold on for a second.
I'm gonna make it a little bit smaller.
Is that too... Is that easy enough to see?
Hopefully.
Maybe... Hold on, I want my background.
Is it okay?
Is it good?
Okay.
Oh my gosh, Cosmic, welcome to membership!
And Zealous!
Zealous, welcome to membership.
Thank you guys.
Yeah, Tokyo Kakeru Shoujo!
Like, actually my favorite movie ever.
You struggle to stand back up.
Your umbrella is lost to the winds.
And so the rain pelts relentlessly on your shoulders.
This is so sad.
Oh, woah, look at the rain.
It goes in whatever direction I'm going in.
Let's see.
Cinema.
It's so cold.
I have to get to the station.
Why don't we stop in Wodonald's first?
I'm so sleepy.
I have to tough it out.
I'm almost there.
Oh my gosh.
No, we have to make it.
Here, we are at the train station.
What about... Let's just go in.
I like... It's almost...
This is the Hotaru no Hikari.
You have no recollection of how you managed to get on the train, or how you reached your dorm.
You only remember opening the door to your dorm groggily and collapsing on your bed, your eyelids closing on their own.
Oh.
But in what feels like the blink of an eye, the alarm clock next to your bed starts ringing incessantly.
You feel just as, if not even more tired than the day before.
This is too real!
I don't like this!
You're going to be late!
It hurts.
Number 996.
Unbelievable.
You failed to follow another basic rule.
You're late.
You're 3 minutes and 20 seconds... No, 3 minutes and 21 seconds late.
As said in the 3 minute rule section in the employee manual, every 3 minutes of tardiness is punishable by deducting 3... 3... 3 days worth of pay!
Eating Mike Tyson's ass!
Thanks for the 10 gift card!
3 days.
You slacked off in the toilet yesterday and now you're late to drill it in that really thick skull of yours.
I'm cutting your paycheck by 50% this month!
The deducted amount will be added to my paycheck!
I'm going to lose it.
I'm going to burn this building down.
Kill him!
Murder is okay!
Says the ghost.
Don't like it?
Then get out of here.
There's plenty more vermin like you scurrying around in the streets.
You're paying for a precious life lesson so you can grow as a person.
When you think of it that way, it's dirt cheap, isn't it?
After enough lessons and some strict telling off, you'll grow into a proper man.
Someday you'll regret not thanking me more.
Do you understand?
Keep it up, Minto.
Your tardiness is costing the company billions.
This company is a family and we all need to pull our...
No, I... we're not going to be whipped around by this guy.
No, I don't!
Bagging groceries doesn't sound so bad.
That's what I'm saying.
I didn't catch that.
Come again?
I quit!
You quit?
Oh my gosh, everybody in the office.
Do you really think anyone else is going to hire you?
You'll come crawling back to me in three days time.
This guy is obsessed with threes.
It's not too late to take it back, you know?
I am a forgiving man.
I quit!
You really think you can quit just like that?
The work you haven't done is going to be pushed onto your colleagues.
You know that, right?
Don't you want your salary?
I can take back the 50% reduction if you insist.
I can't take it anymore!
We're standing up for ourselves.
You still have work to do.
Get back to your desk.
You do it!
Oh my gosh, this guy is really... 404 is missing.
Fine!
Then screw him!
You have three days.
Three days to pack your things and get the hell out of the employee dorms.
Oh god, I'm homeless!
Our company doesn't need a rule breaking piece of trash.
Who doesn't even know how to say thank you?
Goodbye, it was nice knowing you all.
Leave the rest to me.
I'll keep in touch.
I wish you all the best.
Great job!
Maybe you didn't notice, but everyone liked that.
Did you see his face when you talked back to him?
It was straight up cathartic.
You're my hero!
Congrats to your freedom!
Hell yeah!
I quit too!
Good luck out there.
You're amazing!
Oh my gosh, I'm living on this high right now.
Get lost!
Alright!
Live for good!
And Draco's next to the 30 gifted!
Who just clapped?
Fess up!
You have lost your job.
Your new life has begun.
I lost my job!
Oh, I cleared chapter 1.
The convenience store wasn't hiring either.
That's okay.
That's fine.
Yeah, we're unemployed!
I don't have much in savings, so I need to get a new job soon.
And a place to stay too.
Oh, someone's calling me.
It's been a whole day already, huh?
Have you found a new... Oh, this is Senpai.
Talking to us.
Have you found a new job or a place to stay yet?
No?
Yeah, that makes sense.
It was way too sudden.
I don't know if we can be in need if we don't have a home.
You've got to find a place to stay first.
If you don't move out by the third day...
You know who is probably going to toss your belongings into the trash...
And then charge you a disposal fee or something.
Don't worry though.
I'll figure out a way to hide your stuff.
Is that May Dreamin?
It is!
It is actually May Dreamin.
And this is actually Tsurugaya.
Crazy.
Oh my gosh, Moe books!
Moe is justice.
Don't mention it.
You should take the opportunity to get some rest.
We can hang out again once you've settled down.
Oops, 2 minutes and 45 seconds and ticking.
I'll be off.
Talk to you again soon.
That must be Yuki then, probably.
It's still pretty early.
I should look around some more.
Maybe find a place to rest.
Do you guys hear the...
Oh my gosh, it's just like a family mart.
The cats!
Hello master.
Miracle Mint Cafe at your service.
Would you like to pay us a visit?
There's a special event going on today.
Look at the otaku over here.
That's me.
Yes.
Yay!
I have no money, but that's ok.
Our cafe is on the west side of this street.
Just go straight and you'll see it.
We'll be waiting for you.
Ok, but a maid...
You're not really doing your job though.
A maid would guide me to the cafe.
Excuse me?
A maid would be like, oh, you want to come?
Ok, let me lead you to the place.
And they would be very pushy about it.
A maid cafe.
That sounds nice.
Maybe I'll go check it out.
Wait, what's inside Tsurugaya?
Maybe I should check out the maid cafe first.
Look at these.
That's a gacha!
They look like they're having so much fun, but I can't cave in.
I'll come back when I have the money.
Sad.
They are having so much fun.
Hey, do you guys want to be...
Do you want to be nakama?
Do you want to be your tomodachis?
There's a road.
There's a road work up ahead.
So this road is blocked off for now.
I'm sorry for the trouble, but please check another path.
Miracle maid cafe.
Wait, what are these otakus saying?
That's me.
Literally me.
This guy right here.
What?
Hanging out, loitering outside the maid cafe?
Arcade.
I'd love to play once I've gotten a new job.
Okay, let's blow all of our money at the maid cafe first.
I'm terribly sorry, master.
The cafe is full right now.
You'll have to line up outside.
Oh, they're not loitering.
They're lined up.
It's gonna say that maid isn't hustling you for all your cash and being pushy about getting you inside.
So you have to pay out of courtesy.
They're not like... They're not...
I wouldn't say hustling.
As an apology, please take this free trial ticket.
Please come again.
Free trial ticket?
Just because I have to wait outside?
Hey, fellow otaku.
Did you go inside just now?
How's it like in there?
Any seats?
No, huh?
I'll just have to keep waiting.
It's full again and doesn't look like I'll get a seat anytime soon.
That's why I said we should've come earlier.
It's your fault for wasting half a day in Tsurugaya.
Good otaku voice.
Thank you.
You're...
Oh wait, sorry.
I think I've been reading it as the big...
It says big guy, but I've been reading it as the one guy's voice the whole time.
You're the one who refused to leave the arcade.
Are you lining up for Miracle 2?
Join the gang.
Oh right, I've heard that there's another cafe in the westmost part of the street.
Why don't you go scout it out?
Scrawny guy.
Why me?
You go.
I've been walking all day, man.
I don't want to move.
Your head keeps covering the names.
I know!
I'm sorry.
Here, I'll just...
I'll just go down here, okay?
Is this better?
Scrawny guy.
Again.
Westmost part.
I'm a little tired.
If only there was a place I could sit down and take a break.
So, this is west, right?
What do you mean upper left?
What if it's east?
What if they were all wrong and they meant east?
Our cafe is on the west side of this street.
Just go straight and you'll see it.
We'll be waiting for you.
Oh man.
Wait, I can sit here!
East.
This is a nice, like, wallpaper.
You know?
Gosh, I love pixel art so much.
That's why I love my ending screen so much.
It looks so good.
I'm zooming.
Oh my god, I'm, like, speedwalking.
The speed of light.
Nihonbashi station.
Train station.
And this gentleman is Mayoshi.
Made hair fat.
I keep logging the names, okay?
Okay, maybe like this.
I'm just peeking.
Is it Whack Donald's?
Oh my god, this guy is so freaky.
Oh, I can go in!
Sorry, we don't have any empty positions right now.
Okay.
Cinema.
Oh my god.
Are they kissing?
Sorry, but you'll have to try somewhere else.
But the Mugumagi movie.
I want to see it.
Who wants their Minto back?
Wait, this kind of looks like me.
This... the not Sayaka.
Not Sayaka kind of looks like me.
So green, right?
We're not hiring right now.
Sorry.
Are you a restaurant?
High class restaurant?
Oh.
Yes, we're hiring, but we're looking for a certified chef.
Oh, dang.
Leave?
Okay, we can keep going.
This is the cafe they were talking about?
The door is open, so I guess I'll go in.
Oh, so the other cafe is like the super fancy... The other cafe is like at home.
And this one is like the...
The like, you know...
The not so great... The what?
It's a bit run down.
Those are your words.
Let's see.
Fuwa Fuwa.
Mid cafe.
Ghost made of the lake.
What is your wisdom?
What do you mean of the lake?
Oh no!
What do I do?
At this rate the cafe will have to close down for good.
I have to find a new manager.
And fast!
A customer?
Oh no!
What do I do?
Oh my gosh, he's hiding.
The store is so quiet.
There doesn't seem to be anyone here.
Greet!
I'll take a look around before I go.
What do you mean go?
Did you not intend on eating?
I'm observing.
The tables look old, but they're clean and in good shape.
What is this?
What are these decorations?
They have a summoning area.
This is where they draw the pentagram.
They have... The wallpaper is so old it looks like it's about to peel off in places.
Hold on, I'm gonna turn the music just down like 1.
I think it should be good.
Can I go in here?
The lounge.
This cabinet must be antique.
The old fashioned design really adds to the atmosphere.
Is that where they summon you?
Yes.
This maid character looks like mint dipped in ink.
What do you mean by that?
The maids are sad, but it will be OK as soon as you apply the topically administered vaccine.
I know what you're talking about.
What about this fridge?
You've been walking all day.
Maybe you should sit down and take a break.
We're just making it like it's our home.
For years, you spent your life in the frantic war zone of a toxic workplace.
But now, it's as if time itself has slowed down.
Mink?
What do you mean mink?
Ink to mint?
Oh, mink?
You lift your head and look around.
Hopefully you'll be able to relax for a moment.
There's something about this place that makes it so comfortable and warm, as if you were far, far away from the source of your worries.
I love maid cafes.
I love maid cafes!
The wallpaper is falling apart just like your maid cafe when you came back before the renovations.
Oh my gosh, wait!
The wallpaper of this store looks like my gaming background!
Oh my god!
The stripes!
It looks the same!
Oh my god!
My immersion!
You're starting to get sleepy.
Sleepy!
Oh my god, you just fall asleep here.
Check it!
Cute
You'll catch a cold if you sleep here.
Wake up!
Please wake up!
Oh my god, she's so cute!
Look, she even has a hair thing just like me.
Like a little hair barrette on the same side even.
Is this what I would look like if I were human?
I wonder...
Oh, you're up!
Thank goodness!
Good afternoon, master!
I'm one of the maids here.
That's me.
I saw you slumped over the table and got a little worried.
You weren't moving at all for a bit, so I'm just here to make sure you're okay.
You were sleeping so soundly.
I can only imagine how tired you must be.
Same eye color too.
I think this is how I would look if I were human!
Oh my gosh!
I wonder if I would have black hair if I were human.
But you can't sleep here.
You'll catch a cold.
Literally Danny Fett It's best to work hard, rest well, and live a healthy life.
He
even has the same last name as me!
Except it's spelled different.
Not the Danny Fett.
No way.
If you're really exhausted, you should go home and get some proper rest.
It's important to maintain a good work-life balance.
Actually, I wanted to tell you that you can stay here a little longer.
Actually, I'm on a break right now, so I don't have anything to serve you.
But we're not actually open at the moment, so we don't have anything to serve you.
Wait, then why did that maid... Maybe they... I think the maid meant the other place.
Her uniform's different.
I think the maid meant the one that was packed.
Her hair clips are even mint colored.
You're right!
Oh my god.
We got to put mint into that machine that brings ghosts back to life from Casper the movie.
Would you guys still like me even if I were human though?
Maybe you're too used to ghost mint though.
If I were human, would I even be mint?
I wonder.
Would that be my name?
I don't know.
Don't let it go!
The fastest no ever.
If someday the cafe reopens, please come again.
Are we getting kicked out?
Oh, we're both bouncing.
Wait, I want to join.
That was fun.
I'm just saying we can touch human mint though for no particular reason.
What do you mean by that?
Content I joined the channel for.
If someday
the cafe reopens, please come again.
Please wait a moment.
Master, we can make a lot of Fuwafuwa specials, what do you think?
Thank you so much.
Please wait here master.
Oh my gosh, we're in!
We're in!
The Fuwafuwa special!
Why isn't the coffee grinder moving?
Oh, it wasn't plugged in.
Oh god, what is happening in the kitchen?
Now I just push this button to grind the beans, right?
The beans flew out!
Oh no, the powder is getting everywhere!
What do I do?
How do I use this big huge machine again?
Alright, the instruction manual.
Oh god, it's...
Oh no, it's in German!
She can't read it.
100% past life Minky.
Stop it!
Yeah!
Oh well, I guess I'll just add the ground coffee in here.
What was that sound?
It's OK master.
I have everything under control.
Please wait just a little longer.
Even from the other side of the counter, you can tell she's having a hard time.
Lend her a hand?
No, I want to watch her struggle.
What is it this time?
That's strange.
I swear I followed the instructions.
I hope nothing explodes.
She seems to be having a hard time.
Lend her a hand?
No.
What is it this time?
That's strange.
I swear I followed the instructions.
Oh OK, she just repeats.
Lend her a hand.
I guess we have to.
Are you offering to help?
Thank you.
I'll leave it up to you then.
What do you mean leave it up to me?
Oh my gosh.
Let's see.
OK.
According to the owner's recipe, the base for a Fuwa Fuwa Special is an espresso.
Sounds good.
Then you add some milk and cinnamon to taste and you're done.
By a Sabrina Carpenter?
That's me espresso.
We have ground coffee and cinnamon.
And I just bought a carton of milk today.
Choose the base first.
What if I did the wrong thing?
Espresso.
Add.
Then add some milk and a dash of cinnamon.
Milk.
And cinnamon.
Confirm.
Cute!
Baby Corrin, thanks for the five gifted!
Wow, is this really your first time?
You're so talented master!
Serve.
Guys, this might be the kind of service you get when you come to my maid cafe.
Is that OK?
You have to make your own drink.
You have to make your own food.
I just kind of stand there and say, wow, good job!
It's a BYOB.
Bring your own...
Wait, BYOH.
Bring your own hands.
Oh wait, sorry, you're the customer.
You're the one who should be served.
Please take a seat master and I'll bring the coffee to you right away.
Is she going to bless it with some moe moe magic?
You and the maid finished making the cup of coffee together.
Thank you for waiting master.
Here is your Fuwa Fuwa special.
Enjoy!
She just goes...
BYOB.
Be your own butler.
That's good!
Warm steam wafts from the cup of coffee, as well as a familiar aroma that fills the room.
BYO is OK.
Being in Minto's presence is enough.
Bring your own hands?
I'd rather hold yours!
That's against the rules!
What maid-related activity took you to the great cafe in the sky?
Carefully take a sip.
It's still a little hot.
It starts off a bit bitter, but then it slowly mellows out.
The aroma from the cinnamon and the touch of sweetness from the milk rounds out the flavor perfectly.
I hope it doesn't taste weird.
I've rarely been in the kitchen.
You really helped me out just now.
Thank you very much.
I'm Kamigishi Shiro.
I'm a maid of this cafe.
I'm Shiro Kamigishi.
The customers call me Shiro.
I've been working here the longest.
That said, I'm the only one working here right now.
Once in a while?
I come here every once in a while to clean, so I thought that I might as well put the dress on while I'm at it.
I was surprised to find myself hiding under the counter.
I'm sorry.
This is a maid cafe called Fuwafuwa.
This is Fuwafuwa maid cafe.
It's not very big, but it's one of the oldest shops on Electric Street.
We've been closed for a while now, though.
What should I ask?
Oh my gosh.
Why are you closed?
She's very Fuwafuwa.
Because the owner's gone off somewhere.
I knew her voice sounded familiar.
Ikumi Hasegawa.
Voice of Kita Ikuyo from Bochi the Rock.
Ubel the Armpit Girl.
She's been reduced to Armpit Girl from Freerun.
No way.
Wow.
It's kind of stacked.
I wonder what other seiyuu are in this then.
That's crazy.
I'm making the weebs mandatory Tokyo trip.
Are there maid cafes for those who are Nihongo nozu?
In that case, I think you'd be safe at a maid dream inn or at home.
Because usually they have some maids that speak English and also their menus are in English too.
What Shiro just said is kind of insane.
While vacationing overseas, the owner's girlfriend got separated from him and went missing.
Excuse me?
So he just upped and left everything to go look for her.
Last time we talked he was on some remote island in the southern hemisphere.
Excuse me?
Honoka?
Who's Honoka?
No spoilers of seiyuu until we get there.
Or characters please.
Before he left he told me that if I could find a new manager to fill in for him then I could keep the cafe running.
But unfortunately we've never been able to find anyone.
But we're going to make this place huge.
We're going to make this place way better than the other maid cafe.
All those otaku are going to be coming here and being like this is the authentic.
The other place is too corporate.
This place is now so homey and so lovely.
And our maids are perfect and so cute.
And filled with moe moe magic.
Are there any other maids?
Okay, maybe we're in trouble.
So we have no owner, no maids, no fans.
I think we're in trouble.
After the owner left all the other girls quit.
Thank you.
On Sunday I went to my first idol live for my birthday.
It was a kaigai idol seitansai.
I wanted to thank you for inspiring me to try new things and showing me this amazing...
What the world.
Wow, Gliss, I hope you had so much fun.
Kaigai idol seitansai.
Like where you live or in Japan.
The owner ran the cafe as a kind of a passion project.
So it has never really turned to profit.
Usually he would find money from somewhere else to cover the costs.
But that was back when we still had other girls working here.
Find money?
Once he left we couldn't make enough to support the cafe.
What's up?
Wookie!
Thanks for 7 bucks!
Sorry for interrupting.
But what is a good way to speedrun learning Japanese?
Please help me.
Thank you very much.
Hello.
What's up, Minto?
Don't mind for interrupting the stream today.
Good way to speedrun Nihongo.
Maybe...
Become Nihonjin!
You're welcome.
So eventually everyone else just gave up and quit.
Sad.
Have you found someone else?
Wait, she just said that.
Sorry.
I tried looking...
I tried looking everywhere but I couldn't find anyone who would be willing to do it.
Okay.
It is us.
It is I.
Up for the impossible task of love-living this Mint Cafe.
It's not easy to work in this cafe, and I don't have any money.
I don't think there's anyone who would be willing to be the manager.
Someone.
Busuu?
What are you calling him?
Ugly?
Don't call him Busuu.
It's not an easy job, especially since the cafe doesn't make much money.
I can't imagine why anyone would even want the job.
Sometimes I even fantasize of finding someone who is so desperate they have nowhere else to go.
Then I can get them to be the manager.
I reek of desperation.
I think we did everything so...
Wanikani is good for kanji?
Yeah, I like Wanikani.
Are you leaving, master?
Thank you for coming.
I'm sorry for not being able to serve you today, so you don't have to pay anything.
It's on the house.
Take care and please come again.
I want to be your manager.
She's so sweet.
It's been so long since we've gotten a customer.
This must be a good sign.
Sorry, I'm a freak.
Maybe the new manager is right around the corner.
Or right behind you.
I think she's... I think she's asking me.
Bye, there you go.
Thanks for the gift.
Master, would you be interested in...
Never mind.
Please don't worry about it.
But I didn't even... I didn't even like...
Look at me.
I didn't finish my coffee.
This makes me want coffee.
Master!
Would you be interested in becoming the new manager of the cafe?
I can prepare delicious food and support the maids.
If you study a little, you'll get used to it.
It's tough, but it's a fun job.
That's true.
At the very least, that's what I think.
I've been taking a break for almost a year now.
I happened to run into you when I opened the cafe.
I'm sure we're meant to be together.
Somehow I met you here today.
It must be because you're tied to this cafe by fate.
I now pronounce you manager and maid.
You may moe moe the food.
It's okay if you don't want to.
I was just asking.
While I was talking to you, I thought this person would be suitable for the manager.
It would be nice if you could be our manager.
So I thought it would be nice if you could be the new manager.
Just straight out no!
Here, no, no, we're not gonna...
Yeah,
that's fair.
But being our new manager comes with a lot of perks.
Every day with cute girl.
Like...
You can have as many drinks as you want.
You can decorate the cafe however you like it.
She told the truth.
You can work with a bunch of cute girls!
Oh, but I'm the only one left.
Shiro, you're the only one I need.
Oh no, I'm not even cute.
Oh no, I can't think of anything else.
Oh no.
You wouldn't really get anything out of it.
There really isn't anything attractive about this cafe.
But still...
I really like this place!
Why'd you do that?
Anyway, have a safe trip home!
And please come again!
This is literally you.
I'll clean up a bit and go home too.
Why not?
Cute maid is everything I want.
Oh wait, I still need to change the bed sheets in the owner's apartment.
Excuse me, does it...
It comes with a room?
What's the matter master?
Do you need anything else?
A room?
When the owner worked until late at night, he stayed there.
Come to think of it, the owner...
He said it was okay for the new manager to use the room.
He said whoever became the manager could use the apartment.
Since we haven't found a manager yet, the apartment's been empty the whole time.
Thank you for playing this.
You're the reason I discovered and bought the game.
Snow on Steam.
No way!
Happy to hear about it.
Thanks for getting it!
Please let me work here!
You want to work here?
You'll be the new manager?
I mean you just talked about all the perks, right?
This isn't a dream!
Wait, why am I dreaming?
Oh my god, she just hopped.
Yay!
Hip hip!
Hoopee!
Yippee!
She hopped.
So cute.
Then I'll call you manager from now on!
I look forward to working with you, Mr. Manager!
And I'll show you to your room.
The apartment is right above the cafe.
Just take the stairs at the back.
Obtained old notebook.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, Tuna, this one looks like your profile picture.
The owner has Tuna on his wall.
You say Gunpla?
Oh my god, there is Gunpla!
The guy has...I want this poster, whatever this one is.
It's crazy.
Mito CEO.
Mito.
It's literally Mito.
The idol is from Colombia.
She is heavily inspired by J-Idols.
There are also small local groups too.
I posted check-ins on Twitter.
Wow!
That's so awesome!
Tuna's room dogs.
Isn't that so awesome?
This will be your place to stay from now on.
Wandering Zero, thanks for two months!
It hasn't been used in a pretty long time, but I come here regularly to keep it nice and clean.
I love the gravure posters.
It looks like my room.
I feel nice at home here.
So you can sleep here tonight if you want.
By the way, we should probably go over the cafe situation so you understand what you are getting into.
There is a shortage of staff, funds, and customers.
You have gravure photos hanged?
Yeah.
You don't?
I have nudie...
Nudie wasp girls too.
Why do you think I don't have anybody come over?
Well, I took them down for Matara's visit.
But for like gravure stuff, it's like...
A lot of... well, not a lot, but like...
There's like sometimes posters from idols and stuff.
Like gravure posters.
You lack conviction?
I don't need to give her any more ammo on me, okay?
We have three main problems.
Lack of employees, lack of money, and lack of customers.
Well, one of those will solve the other.
The lack of customers will solve... or solving lack of customers will solve lack of money, right?
About the lack of employees.
As you already know, I'm the only person left working in the cafe.
But the cafe needs at least two maids to actually operate.
Maid turquoise.
So our top priority is to find someone who will be our second maid.
Look at her cry.
I've already tried putting up posters for it and everything, but no one's ever shown up for the position.
Let's poach someone from Miracle Maid Cafe.
Let's poach them.
That's kind of scary.
Dang.
Sorry, Miracle Maid Cafe.
Poach them.
Unbiased family thinks for six months.
Yeah, we have fault in them.
We have fault in them.
Steal them.
Now that you're here, it'll be fine.
Yes!
Lack of money.
Sorry, I can't stop yawning.
I thought of coffee and now I just want coffee.
The cafe isn't making enough money to cover its expenses.
Oh no!
The owner left some money for rent, but that's about to run out soon.
Tate!
Tate?
Welcome to Mambo Show!
Thank you!
If the cafe stays closed any longer, we might not be able to pay the next rent.
Oh no!
Wait, does that include the upstairs apartment?
So we have no time to lose!
The owner used it personally, but I borrowed it as part of the cafe.
Oh my god, we can't go homeless again.
Even though the apartment was just for the owner's personal use, it's rented as part of the cafe itself.
If we can't pay the rent, we'll have to return this room as well.
Now that the Big Shell has its own maid cafe, we're gonna need some maids.
Mother Base.
That's why it's called Mother Base.
Because...
Oh wait.
You welcome your mom home!
Or they are your mom.
Wait.
We're workshopping it.
We're workshopping it!
Because your mom is at home, and then the maids welcome you home.
Get it?
We have one maid.
It's Paz.
Not my cat.
Whatever.
You guys don't understand my genius.
If we can't pay rent, the apartment would have to go along with the cafe.
Oh gosh.
Sorry.
It must be fate that you showed up and became the new manager at this exact moment.
About the lack of customers.
I don't get it, but I adore your enthusiasm.
Paz.
Ozzy!
Take your foreburns!
The most popular maid cafe at Electric Street is Miracle Maid Cafe.
Everyone goes there.
And we can't hold a candle to them, either in location or popularity.
What can we do to attract more customers?
You can have a collaboration with the one and only Maid Mint Phantom of Maid Mint Phantom Channel.
Direct hit.
We can organize an event.
A collaboration.
I hear you want to get into UpDog.
I'm impressed.
What's UpDog?
I'll leave that sort of thing to you, manager.
UpDog is getting kicked out of our apartment.
Losing our job.
Our top priority is to find a girl who is willing to work here as a maid.
Let's reopen the cafe as soon as possible.
We should start looking tomorrow.
Or right now.
Could we exchange numbers so we can contact each other?
I obtained Shiro's phone number.
It's getting late.
I should go home.
Good night, manager.
Sweet dreams.
Nice.
This is our room now, huh?
I don't understand what this light is for.
Oh my gosh, the view!
What is...I can't read.
I can't read.
What is the tower called in Osaka?
Do I flip?
No!
Not yet.
Unless we can't save the cafe.
Thank you!
I could only read the ten.
I learned a lot.
What is this?
Oh my gosh!
The hat!
I thought it was the shadow of a person looking out of the bookshelf.
I was like, suddenly it turned into a horror game.
Oh my gosh, it scared me.
Use?
Ah!
Use!
Use.
The computer.
There is something that keeps popping up and I keep missing it.
This?
OK, nevermind.
It's a simple tidy bed.
I'll just have to hold out until my belongings arrive.
OK, turn that off.
Can we observe what's on the wall?
We got our own little bathroom.
This is actually not bad.
This is not bad at all.
Let's go to sleep.
Ready to go to bed?
Yes.
Today was a really long day.
I should go to bed.
I wouldn't be able to sleep, I think.
Today was a nice day.
Good night.
Why can I actually say Mint in this game?
As like a secret side mission character?
This is so cute, the music.
Actually, there is something with this game.
Hold on.
There is an adventurer's tavern in the game.
I saw them post about this earlier on Twitter.
The first 15 players who find the adventurer's tavern and then DM a screenshot to the Twitter account...
I don't know if it's the Playism Twitter account or the Mint Cafe on Electric Street Twitter account.
But the first 15 people who tweet it to the account gets their name in the game.
Isn't that so cool?
Don't reveal to chat.
No, it's okay.
I want people to have their name in the game.
You could say... You could put your name and then say, thanks to Mint Phantom.
Or if I find it, then I'll put my name.
But they only just posted about it today.
They only just posted about it today.
Maybe 15 people haven't found it yet.
Is this a horror game?
No, it's a cozy game.
Don't worry.
Good morning!
Sorry.
I
haven't been able to talk to anyone on the phone in ages, so...
I'm just a little nervous.
I'm getting on the train soon.
I'll be there in 2 or 3 stations, so...
Let's meet up at the station on the east side of Electric Street.
Okay, see you there.
Alright, go to the train station.
Goodbye home?
We didn't shower or anything.
We're kind of disgusting.
Wow!
Good morning, Electric Street!
Good morning!
Or change, yeah.
We're kind of awful.
A friend of mine lives around this area in Osaka.
He showed me this game to him and he says the game made a fairly accurate Nipponbashi.
Really?
That's so fun!
Probably could recognize...
Cute.
The girl sitting on the ground lifts her head a little to look at you.
She's my type!
Oh my god, she's so cute.
Drills.
The girl doesn't respond and only keeps staring at you.
Keep apologizing.
Lend a hand.
The girl hesitates but eventually takes her hand and stands up.
Look at her hair!
Observe the girl.
The girl is rather petite and she's wearing a dark lolita dress with lace frills.
She has light blue meticulously curled hair and her eyes that burn a bright red.
Every feature is as striking as the last.
Her face is as beautiful as a painted porcelain doll, yet her expression feels somewhat cool and mysterious.
She looks like she belongs on the cover of a light novel.
I guess I'll go.
There's no mistaking it.
The girl suddenly speaks.
Fate knows the life of every speck of dust in the universe.
I have foreseen your future.
You will soon be struck by a terrible catastrophe.
Once the gears of fate have started to turn, not even the gods can do anything to stop them.
You stare at the girl with confusion written clearly on your face.
Huh?
Really?
Oh, she's my type!
Oh, she's weird!
Ah, she's a freak!
I am the slayer of the false god, the queen of the kingdom of darkness, the all-seeing oracle, the guardian of all dreams!
Fafna.
Fate.
Fate brought us before each other.
Now, do as I say, so that you may be saved.
But of course, salvation comes with a price.
She's so cute.
She's cute.
From now on, she'll be known as Lulu.
No!
She's a Fafna!
If it's money you want, then forget it.
Fang!
She's perfect.
I won't charge you for anything, promise!
But if you don't listen to me, you'll be cursed with bad luck.
You'll encounter ceaseless maladies and misfortunes.
I mean...
You'll be really unlucky and you'll definitely regret it.
Fafna, huh?
Sounds familiar.
To what?
Oh, we're becoming her familiar?
You won't make a good familiar at this rate.
The girl's expression turns into one of panic.
Her cool and mysterious demeanor is shattered in an instant.
A familiar?
Don't worry about that right now.
Oh my gosh, we're gonna become a familiar.
She seems to be trying to appear dignified again.
I believe in you.
Someday, you will repay my debt.
Why can't encounters like this happen to me?
Why is afterlife so cruel?
Why can't this hap...
Is everything okay?
Sorry, my OBS just disconnected for some reason.
The encounter!
We're back, we're good.
Sorry about that.
Sorry, my OBS got a little funky.
I believe that you will repay me in something that is worth far more than money.
Job experience.
She puts a hand in her pocket.
Now, accept my blessing.
This will bestow upon you the power to slay the false god.
A 401k.
Oh my gosh, she's so cute.
Who is her seiyuu?
It's gone?
But I still had it when I left the bookstore.
Where did it go?
Press confirm to investigate your surroundings.
The thing right here?
Literally the thing right here?
Oh wait, this thing right here.
Paid in exposure.
Nijika from Bocchi?
Ah, Sayamizu Shiro.
Wow, stacked?
What is this?
You found a broom leaning on the wall of the bookstore.
You spot something in the corner.
Try to take it.
You reach with your hand, but it's out of range.
You might need a tool.
Leave it.
I will grab the broom.
Ask if you can borrow it.
You ask someone in the bookstore to lend you the broom.
They said yes.
Obtained broom.
Investigate.
Try to get it out with the broom.
We got the mysterious silver pendant.
Hey, were you looking for this?
But when you look around, the strange girl is nowhere to be seen.
Nothing new.
You return the broom and put the pendant in your pocket.
Information about Fafnir.
Where'd she go?
My queen!
I am your familiar!
I
can't tell what this last one, this one on the far right is referencing.
Oh my god, pop fiction.
Like this poster.
I can't tell what it's referencing.
H-Max?
No, no, the one on the bottom.
There we go.
The one the character is standing next to.
Realize there's a Madoka look-a-like poster.
There is, right?
Yeah, it's cute.
It's Muguka.
Mugumagi.
Conan?
Go dance with this.
What do you mean with the nugget?
A girl who left her time?
No.
There is one, yeah.
That one.
The one that just appeared is the girl who left her time, but...
I can't tell.
Conan.
I don't think it's Conan.
Why are you dancing in front of the...
Wodonalds?
Why are you dancing in front of the Wodonalds?
This is how you sound!
The BGM makes me think of Nyangostar.
The JP Metal Drummer mascot from that one video where he goes way too hard on the cue music.
I don't know that one.
It kind of looks like Conan.
I don't know.
It's going to drive me crazy.
Oh my god!
Hitting Mike Tyson's ass.
Welcome to Mambo Ship.
Happy New Year!
She's in casual clothes.
I thought she would be in a maid outfit.
When you arrive at the station, a girl with black hair catches your attention.
You notice that she has headphones on.
She looks around at the crowd as if looking for someone.
It's Chido.
She looks a little different outside of her maid dress.
She doesn't seem to notice you there.
Watch her.
She seems to be enjoying her music.
She bounces to the rhythm and even strikes a cute pose.
But perhaps hit by a sudden wave of embarrassment, she quickly stops and pretends nothing ever happened.
But this has happened to me before, especially when listening to Seikan Hiko from Macross.
Like my hand instinctively does the Kira.
So I understand.
My hand goes Kira.
I'm watching her.
I'm looking at her clothes.
She's wearing mint?
Greet her.
She's wearing mint clothing.
When did you arrive?
After 12 months I'm finally a licensed...
Lily, please!
You're a jerk in it!
Where
did you go in here?
I'm glad you seem to be doing better today.
This lady looks like she's going through it.
Let's do our best.
Let's find ourselves a new maid.
That's a cute outfit.
No it's not!
I wear this all the time!
I was a little worried he wouldn't recognize me since I'm not in my maid dress.
It's not that cute.
We've only met twice so far.
You keep trying to flatter me.
It's not very nice manager.
Come to think of it, I also asked the manager for a job when we first met.
I'm confused that her sprite has pink but her dress is actually white.
I guess I did ask a total stranger to become the manager of a cafe, huh?
That's probably not very nice either.
Yeah, it's probably also not very wise.
Any freak can become the manager.
Like me.
I'm the freak.
Yeah, I'm fine.
Sorry.
I'm good.
We've got to find someone who will work alongside us today.
That way we'll be able to reopen the cafe.
So let's give it our best shot.
What should I say?
I'm looking forward to our date today.
This is actually technically a sign.
Don't tease me like that manager.
What should I say?
Let's say how do we find a maid.
Okay, we'll start by walking around town.
There's a lot of different shops at Electric Street.
We might run into a new maid candidate if we're lucky.
Probably.
If we're very lucky.
No, I worked here.
You don't know this place very well yet, do you?
I'll show you around.
Let's just... I think we're good about the other stuff.
Actually, why Electric Street?
I'm curious.
This is just what I've noticed personally, but I feel there are more girls here that might be interested in maid cafes.
Hmm...
You spend 19 hours a day in an office?
How would you know the area?
Okay, true.
Okay, that's very fair.
Never mind.
We had to eat sometime, right?
If you go anywhere else and ask random girls on the street, do you want to become a maid or something like that?
They might think you're suspicious and call the police.
They think you're suspicious or worse, they might...
Call the police!
Okay, I think we know enough about becoming a maid.
Let's go.
I'll be right behind you.
Okay, do you want to become a maid?
Welcome to the Electric Street Station.
You can use an IC card to travel around Osaka, but I would also recommend the one-day pass.
She's right behind me.
Okie dokie, cop maid.
She's right behind me, isn't she?
Minto, a girl behind you.
Mama.
Let's start looking for a new maid.
We have to keep our eyes peeled for cute girls.
Whether anyone cute comes by is all down to luck, so let's take it easy.
That's right!
Manager-san, is there anywhere you'd like to go?
Let's take a look around the electric district.
Where?
Zatsudan button?
If you want to talk to me about something, just press the... I almost said it, the chat button.
Oh my gosh, the Zatsudan button, everybody.
Continue your search on Electric Street, you can talk to Shiro with the chat button.
V.
Anywhere you want to go?
Oh, that's all she says.
This girl is kind of cute.
Cute girl.
As much as I run, I can't get below it.
Maybe in the arcade there's some cute girls.
Manager, please come over here quick.
Let's go to the second floor.
What's on the second floor?
There's something I want to show you.
Did that say Adventurer's Tavern?
Where?
No!
Wait, Adventurer's Tavern!
It did?
Is this where all the Otoge is?
Oh no.
Magic Angel Lilith of the Moon and the Idols of the Twelve Stars.
Just Magic Angel is fine though.
Where's the Wakka tab?
I'm really sorry to tell you, but...
You might want to find a new game.
Magic Angel isn't the most popular game out there just yet, but thanks to the comics, light novels, and offline live concerts, it's definitely going to be the next big thing.
The anime starts next year too!
At first glance, the setting of the idols seems to be very common, but that's not the case!
This is a new style!
Wait, Shiro, I love you, but I need to go be one of the first 15 people!
The magical girl and idol themes probably sound really overdone, but it's super well made and has so much love and effort put into it, so I know it's going to set a new standard for other media like it.
I want to be in the game!
People only hate things that are clich or overdone when they're badly made, but Magic Angel is so high quality it's leagues above the other franchises.
Not to mention, the first thing it has are tried and true tropes!
So I personally think this is way better than adding weird tropes to tried and tested formulas just to appear different and shocking.
These people have no love for genres they're creating for!
That's right.
Love is the most important thing.
And when you play Metal Gear...
Love is the one thing that makes people move.
Ah, I'm sorry!
I got carried away there.
Let's get back to the topic.
This arcade game, Magic Angel, is the origin of all the series.
It's a game where you use real trading cards to play.
The player receives the support of Lilith, the little devil of the moon.
What a nerd.
It's a trading card game where you use real physical cards.
The player supports the cute moon devil Lilith, who produces 12 idols and assigns them to fight alien monsters.
She's so cute.
Aren't the idols lying down in the room in the main menu so cute?
When the mission is successful, the idols who defeated the alien monsters sing and dance live.
With the income from the live, they strengthen their idols and equipments and fight again.
So true!
Once they beat an alien monster and clear the mission, the idols who fought hold a live concert.
And then you use the money earned from the concert to upgrade your idols and gear before going on the next mission.
There's this cheeky character...
There's this cheeky character called Lililana.
And she's super cute.
I grinded so much for her banner.
And when I finally got her, I spent so much time poking her for interactions.
I forgot to play the actual game.
So if I ever get the chance... Wait, if you ever get the chance, you will have to try it.
However, if I don't find a maid today, I won't be able to enter the world of magic.
You're already in the game, bitch.
But our
mission today is to find a new maid for the cafe.
We don't have time to get lost in the world of magic and music.
Hold on, we'll come back.
Oh, I think we have to... Maybe we go upstairs.
How do we get in there?
Wait, hold on.
Let me see what the thing says on here.
Who find adventurer's tavern and tell us how they got there.
How do we get in there?
Second floor.
Sounds like it might be a secret entrance.
I think so too.
Hmm...
This is the most popular photo booth machine right now.
The photos are really high-res and there's a bunch of cute frames and filters to choose from.
There's a loading thing that said it's open at night.
It's really easy to make anyone take...
Wait, it makes it really easy for anyone to take cute photos.
J-MAX, look at the membership.
Puri.
Puriki.
Can't believe photo booths survived the 80s.
Wait, if you don't know the Purikura though, it's like so...
popular.
In Japan, Purikura.
Is what I know.
Never heard of it called the Puriki.
It's like...
But they make your eyes really...
buggy.
They make your eyes like...
like an alien.
And then they kind of like...
do a beauty filter on your face.
And I actually have one that I took with Emiri.
Emiri and I got...
We got our hair done in Japan together.
My friend Emiri.
And we did Purikura together.
And I have our Purikura...
on my...
on like a little board above my computer.
It's cute.
Except...
We look like aliens.
Let's take a photo together.
It's kind of embarrassing.
Maybe next time.
I never know when to stop, when to start.
Promise.
Let's come back to take a photo once we successfully reopen the cafe.
It's a promise.
Wait, what did they say upstairs?
I guess we have to wait then for night time.
I want to try the game.
Why are there so many bathrooms here?
I want to play Magic Angel.
Our enemy.
How do we get to Adventurer's Tavern?
It says Purikura, second floor.
Arcade, third floor.
There must be a secret to get to the Adventurer's Tavern.
We'll wait for it to be night time, I suppose.
Surugaia!
Look at her!
From Magic Angel?
She's so cute.
I needed this.
This Aqua also looks really nice.
Might as well get the whole team while I'm here.
Where are the other badges?
There you are.
Yay!
OK, that's all for today.
Oh...
The 5th anniversary merch is the little order... wait, sorry.
Is the order a little sister?
Yes, please!
Gochu?
Gochi?
Wait, it's Gochiusa.
Gochiusa is the...
short version.
Is the order a potato?
I was thinking that too.
Tomorrow is Chino's birthday?
No way!
I think right now at Atre in Akihabara...
Maybe not right now.
Or maybe...
Recently it was a Gochiusa.
I love how it's like a combination of probably Gochiusa and then Oreimo, right?
Oops!
Now that's all for today.
Please wait here, Miniature.
I'll go pay for all my new merch.
OK, I'm not gonna judge her.
You guys, we need to super chat Chino!
Considering making 50 different alts to post on the tweet just to make sure Minto couldn't get in his revenge...
for not getting a puppet.
What are you talking about, Kinky?
The puppets are still open!
You can still get one!
They're on pre-order for the second badge!
Also, it's only 15, not 50.
You would've wasted your time making 50 accounts, super chatting Chino.
Second badge just woke on it.
Pass the Supazon please, boss.
I will, because I am the boss.
I will pay her handsomely.
Enough for food next week.
Really?
Wait, what do you mean really, Vivicore?
Because if you mean about the plushies, yes.
Yes, really.
People have been buying them still.
I've been watching the number go up.
I've actually been avoiding Tsurugaya lately because I wanted to fight by spending urges, but...
I didn't see what the choices were!
Oh my gosh.
What were the choices?
Oopsie.
I accidentally just picked something because I thought it was me going to... I didn't realize there were choices there.
Chino, will you date me?
Chino super contribution?
Suddenly money.
Actually, there's also some merch that I pre-ordered, so by the time that releases, my savings will...
Maybe I should just give up?
She don't need money.
But look how happy she is.
Food is temporary.
You can become a ghost and still love your waifus.
I thought about it, but as long as we find a new maid today, we can reopen the cafe tomorrow and I'll get paid!
Super for Goshiro.
So it's fine.
All we have to do is find a maid by the end of the day.
This is fun!
I can feel a huge weight on my shoulders.
Cute!
There are lots of new arrivals.
Please look around.
What do you have to buy?
Oh my gosh!
It's the order a little sister movie poster!
Change tapestry.
Change tapestry tool.
Booksia archive.
Archive?
It's not based off a blue archive.
Oh my goodness.
In the game books... Maybe Wooshia archive?
Wooshia?
Wooshia.
Animal Street!
Animal Street.
Denmon Amethyst.
Nice.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
It's just Valhalla!
Sorry, I was so focused on the archive part.
I was like, oh haha, blue archive.
La Mulana?
What?
Rose and Camellia.
I don't know this one.
Wait, there are some actual things.
Rose and Camellia.
La Mulana.
Aren't they re-releasing that?
Soon?
In like a...
In like a thing?
It's the Ojo-sama slapping game.
Let's talk to her.
This week's working schedule and super common event will conflict.
Maybe I should change the shift.
Okay.
Nothing else around here?
Okay, let's leave.
What else we got?
We got Famistop.
We've got...
He should be right here!
He should be right there!
It removes the... What is this?
Snake erasure?
Snake, where are you?
Snake!
Oh my gosh.
Mazindam.
They should have at least put like a guy that...
Like Splinter Cell Man or something.
Not even a box.
Cute!
She sits right next to me and we're like kind of blinking at each other.
Snake is dead.
Don't say that!
You've created a time paradox.
Let's see inside the Famistop.
It's quite nice in here.
This Famistop, they have everything from snacks to daily necessities.
I think it's funny that like... Can you imagine...
Like, you know, being a Nihonjin and someone trying to explain to you what Family Mart is?
Since it's the Electric Street Famistop, they might have special items you can't find anywhere else.
Seasonal watermelon soda!
I love limited items.
I always get...
I always get got by seasonal items.
I'm just like...
Limited?
Buys.
You
get it.
You watch Shiro run to the drinks fridge.
Then comes back with her arms full of snacks.
I keep buying too much.
Let's share some of it together.
I was trying to say tomorrow.
Together.
Yes, together.
Oh, what can we buy here?
Welcome.
What are you looking for?
We got Pocori.
Anpan!
I love Anpan.
Makeup set.
Should be a good gift for girls.
Rakumi barley tea.
Yummy!
Exclusive.
Nippon Bashi.
Exclusive packaging.
Wow.
Deluxe golden fatty tuna flavor cat food.
So we're gonna get the cats later too.
Nice.
What does this guy have to say?
Once I'm done with cashier work, I have to clean.
Then restock the shelves.
I thought working here would be easy, but there is so much work to do.
I'm part time worker.
Fatty tuna.
Yummy.
You will be mine kittens.
Look how cute that little guy is.
Cat.
Okay, we went to Tsurugaya.
We can't go this way, right?
There is road work.
Adventurer's tavern.
You will be mine.
We can't go into soft map.
Oh, we can go into Wodonald's.
This place has a limited time menu that comes with extra goodies, like anime or video game tie-in merch.
You should stop by when you have the time.
Oh my gosh, I thought that was actually me for a second.
You're not eating yet?
Let's have lunch together.
Welcome, may I take your order?
She's flirting with me.
We're gonna have...
It's not...
Oh my god, my credit card is on the screen.
You guys, don't look, okay?
Don't look.
This is no fast kitchen, so...
But we'll still get the fries.
How many burgers can I order?
What if I order a lot of the whole menu?
Not enough money!
Oh, I only have 800.
We'll share a fry.
I'll have a usual one serving of large fries.
Just a moment please, we'll get it ready for you right away.
Oh my gosh!
Cinema.
What's in theaters?
The movie.
This is...
Manager-san, is that girl your little sister?
The movie is being re-released.
A must-see best 5 for those who like little sisters.
I can't believe I'm seeing it on the big screen again.
Let's watch it right now, before they stop showing it.
Wait, we're still looking for a new maid.
We don't have time for this.
But...
I still want to watch it.
I really want to watch it.
Let's keep looking for a new maid before I give in to temptation.
What is this movie though?
What is this rep?
Is it JoJo?
No.
The logo at the bottom looks almost like it's supposed to look like JoJo.
Like the logo, you know?
The JoJo logo.
One ticket please.
I have... Wait, backup for the future.
The celebration!
That's my queen!
The college student Rika visits an old lady living alone as part of her volunteer activities.
But the house is haunted by the ghost of Kyarako.
A housewife who was killed before she could celebrate her son's birthday.
The people around Rika coincidentally visit the house on their birthdays, but start dying one after another.
Finally, it's Rika's turn to join in the celebration.
I love Ju-on!
I love it.
Backup for the future.
The high schooler Murphy...
Oh my gosh, Murphy, you didn't tell me that you found the Adventurer's Tavern.
Tavern.
Gets transported 30 years into the past by a time machine invented by his friend and scientist, Dr. Dog.
Dr. Dog.
However, Murphy accidentally deletes the design data of the time machine in the past, which would mean the time machine would never exist.
He'll have to recover the data with Dog's help.
But it's not as easy as it looks.
Dr. Dog.
Coco, who just became a high school student, gets lost on her way back from school.
She finds herself in a bakery called Rabbit Room, where she meets her estranged half-brother and his pet kitten.
Her life as a new little sister of pastry chef starts here.
Why do I want to watch it so bad?
I would watch.
OK.
Can we... I mean, I have enough money.
I have 2,000.
But I could only buy one ticket.
She probably wouldn't mind if I just watched it by myself.
We don't know each other that well, you know.
I wish I had someone to talk about movies with.
Maybe I should go drinking with Yuasa-kun again.
She'll hate you forever?
You're right.
Maybe I should watch...
We're gonna go watch it?
What if I buy the wrong movie?
No, we'll go get it.
Wait, don't tell me.
Do you want to watch Is the Order a Little Sister, the movie?
I mean, it's still the afternoon, so we'd still have plenty of time after the movie.
We'll get inspiration.
We haven't done what we came for yet.
We could look for a new maid after the movie.
Couldn't we?
Says the obvious.
I suppose we can.
Brilliant strategy manager.
Let's do that.
We're a genius.
If you want to watch the movie so badly, I'll join you.
Let's watch the movie and be reinvigorated by the holy power of emotos!
That should help us with our search later.
One student ticket, please.
Here you go.
One adult ticket, one student ticket.
Enjoy your movie.
It's me in the back.
Did you trip over your own feet again?
Can't you even escort your own little sister properly?
You're such a pathetic older brother.
Baka!
Kirino-chan, don't say that.
Your brother did his best.
Oh geez!
Kiri, are you alright?
Does it hurt?
I'll kiss your boo-boo so it gets better.
Coco, stop spoiling my brother.
Helping a loser like him is just a waste of time.
Buy recipes to unlock coffee ingredients.
Yeah, Shiro does have a bad taste.
How could you think Kirino-chan is the cutest when Kuro Inu Inu is right there?
Kuro Inu!
The main character didn't even deserve her.
So cute!
Little sisters are so cute!
Especially Kirino-chan with how she can't express herself well around her brother.
This much cuteness should be illegal!
Welcome, welcome.
I hope you had a fun stream.
I'm Mint Phantom.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Doki, thanks for the gifted.
Rumia, thanks for the gifted.
Mervy, thanks for the bag gifted.
We're playing a silly game about having to save a maid cafe.
And right now we're trying to find maids, but we're getting really distracted by little sisters.
I can't see it, too.
Thanks for the gifted!
Teacup!
You changed.
Thanks for the gifted!
Dokizo, thanks for the gifted!
Starcated, thanks for the five gifted!
Sirstreak, thanks for the five gifted!
Tsundere, truly the most blessed trope among tropes.
Serious angel.
Coco-chan is really cute, too.
She's so nice that she won't leave her brother's side when he's sad.
She's such an angel.
She's himself, thanks for the five gifted.
If only I could be surrounded by cute imoutos like that.
Oops, I can't start drooling here.
Why did I have to be the imouto?
I always wanted imouto, but I also always wanted a brother.
I only have a sister.
I want imouto.
I don't want to be the imouto.
Why can't I have a little sister?
I think the god should give every single person a little sister.
It's only fair.
A brother.
I've always wanted a brother.
I love how Chido keeps releasing her power level.
She's perfect.
I hope our new maid will be as cute as a little sister.
So true.
I hope so too.
Why can't we go to the guild now?
Or to the tavern?
Oh, it's getting dark and you haven't found anyone.
You decide to walk Chido to the station.
Wait, if god gave everyone a little sister then the little sisters would also have a little sister and then the imouto overflow.
Never ending imouto.
True.
Don't think too hard about it.
Infinite imouto glitch.
Basically.
I should probably go home.
It's been a while since I spent a whole afternoon here.
The only people with imouto interests are the people who don't have IRL little sisters.
Mostly.
But that's why I have one imouto.
Maybe.
Well then goodbye manager.
See you tomorrow.
Wait a minute.
We were supposed to find a new maid today.
Where are we?
Wait, what do we do?
We won't be able to open the cafe tomorrow at this rate.
Oh my god, hot girls walking by.
Sorry, coming through.
Oh my gosh, pink haired girl.
Sorry.
Thanks.
Oh my god, look at them.
They are the hot girls.
They are the hot girls in Nipponbashi.
Wow!
They look popular.
They don't need us.
Oh wait, I forgot to buy lipstick.
I'm running out.
You guys go first.
We can go.
Oh, red haired girl is...
Elizabeth?
Herb?
Tan herb?
They are not popular.
They are not good enough to get voiced.
We can go with you.
No, I'll be fine on my own.
Oh my gosh, I like her.
I like her buns.
And her... and her... and her buns.
Damn girl!
Mio, why do you keep sneaking away on your own lately?
Wait, don't tell me.
Did you get a boyfriend?
Just gyaru, Monika.
Kind of.
I see it.
No way.
If I get a boyfriend, you two would be the first to know.
For real?
I know I would keep it a secret for a while until we like start talking about boys and stuff.
And then I'd take out a pic of my boyfriend and be all like...
You guys have no idea how annoying my boyfriend is.
I'll come like... so you don't even see it coming.
Misaki-poi.
That's so you.
Okay, but if it isn't a boy, what is it?
Where do you keep sneaking off to?
The arcade.
I still haven't cleared the limited time event yet.
Oh, okay.
Wait, how do I do a British accent?
You go do that then.
We'll go home.
Bye.
Tell us if you do get a boyfriend.
You
guys, I'm so sorry.
I keep just thinking that I'm clicking here and I'm not looking up here.
So I keep not seeing that there's prompts.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know what I just clicked again.
She said something about a limited time event.
Manager, let's follow her!
Oh, I called her cute?
Okay, I would've picked that anyway.
You're so right.
What?
I'm just walking!
I'm walking here!
What are you talking about?
Oh, okay.
So we have to do it without her noticing.
Oh, I see that the level goes up.
Nothing?
Oh, we can hide.
I just noticed.
Oh, where'd you go?
Nowhere to hide here.
Sneaking mission, guys.
Sneaking mission.
There's the game center.
She went into the arcade, just as I thought!
If this goes well, we'll convince her in no time!
Let's go, manager, for Fuwa Fuwa!
Is there a way to get into...
Maybe Adventure's Tavern unlocks here and I go through some back roads or something.
I don't know.
Fuwa Fuwa.
What do we do?
We've lost sight of her!
Oh, okay, nevermind.
Oh, okay, you can't lose sight of her, but you can't... Okay, let her see you either.
Uh-oh.
Okay, I have to hide in there, I think.
Yeah, we have to hide here.
Okay.
Oh, wait!
Let me hide!
Okay, hold on.
Oh gosh!
Oh my god, please!
Okay, restart.
Okay.
Turn around.
Hide.
There we go.
Okay.
Vtuber Y, sorry!
It was...
Manager, come closer!
We can see outside from here!
By the time you notice that Shiro smells kind of nice, you're practically attached to each other!
Notice like this, you attempt to put some distance between you, but...
Manager, don't move!
We're losing her!
Shiro pulls you back in.
Your face is touched!
I'm sorry.
I don't think the heartbeat is just from following her.
What was that?
In your panic...
One of you accidentally pushes a button on the photo machine.
A joyful voice rings out of the speakers, oblivious of the bad timing.
Congratulations!
You won a chance for one free photo!
Get ready for your free photo!
Say cheese!
Thank you for coming!
See you again!
Oh
my god, he is such a string bean!
It's okay.
They put all of the effort into the girl.
That's all that matters, right?
All the drawing effort.
Must have been my imagination.
She's gone.
Alright, let's get out.
That was close.
At least we got a free photo out of it.
Looks like they printed...
Looks like they printed out too.
What should we do with them?
Eat it.
Give Shiro one of the photos?
You keep both for yourself.
What are you going to do with both of them?
Keep both.
I'm going to put one in the bathroom where the toilet is and one in the shower room.
Anyway, let's follow her upstairs.
Right there should be perfect.
Look, there she is!
Actually, you know how some people... Okay, I'll put one in the shower room.
And then, you know how some people put the pictures of something above their bed?
That's where I'll put the other one.
So I go to bed and I look up at my ceiling and I'm like...
Right here should be perfect.
Look, there she is!
Excuse me.
Oh man, I got to do the limited time boss fight but none of my teammates are online.
Men keep a wallet copy.
Really?
I have check keys in my wallet.
Is it the same?
Not even SR46 is online.
Shiiro?
Oh my gosh.
4 can be read as Shi and 6 can be read as Ro.
It's Shiiro.
All you need to do is register with this machine.
Now I'm standing here watching?
Play the adjacent arcade machine.
Look how bouncy she is, even in this seat.
This girl doesn't need anymore coffee.
Because the cafe only has coffee, that's all she's been drinking and eating for the past whole year that the manager has been gone.
So she's just always got that caffeine in her.
Manager, this limited boss drops rare items.
I don't know if we can win with just 2 people, but let's do our best.
Wait, my friend is online too, so we can fight in a team of 3.
Oh, I wonder who your friend is.
Kokoro joined your team.
Kokoro!
I have a box I keep at...
I thought you said you have a box you keep at Daiso.
I have a box I bought at Daiso that I keep my check keys for Checky Meshy and plus extra sleeves when I buy new ones.
Definitely recommend it.
I have to go to Daiso and get one.
Wait, can you send a picture later, Ashes, on Twitter?
Can you post a picture?
I have to get another Checky album.
Because I have...
1, 2, 3, 4...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5...
I had to rearrange my bromides recently because I had to...
I filled up another album of them.
I have to get another Checky album because all of my...
I have a Checky album that's completely full now of one idol.
But the Checky album is not themed to her.
So I have to get another one.
Now I gotta...
I think all 5 are full too, so...
I gotta buy another one.
My albums are full.
After a grueling battle you emerge victorious.
We did it!
GG desu!
Thank God!
Thank God Shiro hopped on in time.
No idea why they brought a newbie with them though.
GG desu!
Kano-chan, she...
No, there's no way.
Are you Kokoro?
No way, are you Shiro?
Are you friends?
She's Kokoro, the player who beat the boss battle with us just now.
Stargaze, welcome to Manbuship.
Thank you!
Maybe...
She's my best partner.
Such a small world, right?
I never thought it'd go like this, but I'm really happy to meet you in real life.
Same here, Shiro.
I'll introduce myself for realsies then.
My name is Miyu Kosaka.
I'm Shiro Kamigishi and this is the manager.
This is the manager.
Thank you for the pizza!
I have pizza for dinner.
Well, it's leftover pizza.
The manager?
Nice to meet you.
Not at the arcade, right?
What does he manage?
We run a maid cafe called Fuwa Fuwa Cafe.
It's on the west side of Electric Street.
Cute!
That sounds cool.
I'll go visit next time.
Oh no, time to trauma dump on to this girl we just kind of met today.
Thank you so much.
The thing is though, we're actually in serious trouble right now.
Shiro tells Miyu about the cafe and its situation.
You're in serious, serious trouble?
Yeah, the VA and the cash in this are like stocks actually.
Miyu,
do you want to be a maid?
Like right now?
I know it's a lot to ask.
You don't have to say yes.
But please, at least come take a look at our cafe!
I like how bouncy the girls are though.
It's fun.
Doing part time jobs at restaurants is a way to earn some more pocket money.
What does that mean?
We're not going to get enough money?
Welcome back, master.
Sorry to make you wait.
Give me a second.
I like them bouncy.
Shiro quickly dashes into the locker room.
Oh, she's got a change.
She's a totally different person offline.
But she's like online now.
She's a real go-getter online.
She gets real angry when she loses too.
Kind of scary even.
She's a gamer!
You can't picture it, huh?
I getcha.
Alright, and did you know that Shiro...
They haven't met in real life until today, but it seems like they're already really good friends.
That's so cute!
My god, she's really mean.
Stop!
I'm back!
What were you talking about?
Is that your maid uniform?
So cute!
Do you want to try on the uniform too, Miyu?
You'd look really good in it.
I'm sure of it!
I'll show you to the locker room!
The two girls practically skip towards the locker room, chatting away happily.
Leaving you... all alone.
No choice but to wait, I guess.
15 minutes later.
Holy moly, it took so long.
What do you think?
If the devs were to reveal that Shiro was inspired by you, I wouldn't be surprised at all.
Stop, I don't think so.
I think it's probably just a coinkidink.
Miyu has changed into a maid outfit too.
Hey, you don't have to stare at me like that.
It really suits you.
It really does suit you, Miyu.
The manager should be me, not him.
Me too.
I'm starting to get embarrassed.
Won't you consider becoming a maid?
I'll sound really manager-like.
Fine, I'll give it a shot.
Just don't expect too much from me.
Manager-san, you did it!
You're a new maid!
We did it, manager!
We recruited a new maid!
You and Shiro cheer happily.
Finally, it's over.
It's a little hop.
It's so funny.
Tomorrow's the day Fufu will finally reopen.
Tomorrow?
That soon?
I've been waiting for this day for so long.
Of course, I've been waiting for this day for so long.
Then, Miyu and I will go shopping.
Manager-san, please prepare for tomorrow and rest up.
No, Miyu and I still have work to do.
Manager-san, you can't listen.
Shiro and Miyu leave the cafe together.
I should go back to the apartment.
Miyu joined your staff!
You returned to your room and slept soundly.
It's morning!
Time to manage the cafe for the very first time!
Wait.
Yes, I do want to save my progress.
We cleared chapter 2.
Oh, there we go.
Playthrough 1?
Wow.
I wonder if there's some new game plus stuff then.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
We have 1,000 yen.
We have a single sentence to our name.
Oh gosh.
Welcome to membership!
I think I remember seeing that there's like...
I mean, we already saw Valhalla and some other...
other game collabs.
But I think there's like a few more too, so...
That's fine.
Different routes probably.
Probably, probably, probably.
Guys, I think I'm going to end it here for today.
So far, this is so cute.
I'm so sad we couldn't...
I thought we would get... What was her name?
Fa...
Fafna.
I thought we would get Fafna today, but...
Unfortunately, we got to meet...
We only got to meet her, which actually...
I shouldn't say unfortunately.
You know what?
That was a splendid encounter.
Anytime I get to meet a chunibyo...
I am blessed.
I feel like I could go back to heaven.
Wait, Mint, you like maids?
Don't get it twisted.
I love maids.
I don't just like maids.
I live, breathe...
Well, I'm dead.
If I were alive...
If I were alive, I would...
I would breathe.
I would sleep.
I would eat maids.
I love maids.
They are my afterlife stream.
It's my ectoplasm blood stream.
It's in my DNA.
I love maids.
Hold on.
It's my birthday tomorrow.
Can I get a happy birthday from my Oshi?
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, perfected flies.
Happy birthday!
Thank you for the superchat!
If you love maids so much, why don't you become one?
Check it.
Headband.
Apron.
Thigh high.
I became the maid.
Ahoge.
Check it.
I became the maid.
Feed us Omurice.
I can serve you Omurice.
Does cuteness check too?
I guess...
Every maid is technically cute.
Because they are a maid.
But I'm only cute because my mama made me that way.
That's why.
Maids are so cool.
I wish they were real.
I wish so too.
I'm so glad I live in a...
Gosh, I'm so glad I'm dead in a timeline where maids exist.
I hope you can visit Osaka one day.
Me too!
Me too, me too, me too.
I want to go to Nipponbashi now.
Sure princess, thank you!
Oh sorry.
There it is.
Remember when Chiyo thinks she isn't cute?
Yeah, she's you.
You're cute because you are Minto.
I'm Minky.
I'm Minky now.
I reject Minto.
I'm Minky.
Minky.
This is fun though guys.
Thank you so much.
I hope you guys enjoyed so far.
Check please.
What is this?
Minky and...
No, don't combine it.
I actually have to send this.
Playism actually asked if I could send when I play the game to them.
So I will be sending this to them and be like...
Hi, I think Chiyo is accidentally me.
Cool.
But yeah, I don't know.
I might play this, like finish it off stream.
When I have time, which is...
I...
I think...
I don't know.
I don't know if I want to finish streaming it or what.
We'll see.
Please stream it.
I'll think about it.
Sorry.
Minky extra cute.
Minky!
We need to know how made cafes are run.
I feel like we didn't really get to any of the gameplay, right?
Like the actual taking care of the made cafe part.
So, maybe I will stream it.
Saying you're cute and got it from your mama resurfaced a song I got it from my mama by Will.i.am.
And now I want to hear you sing it.
I don't know that one.
You're still in the tutorial.
We're on chapter 2.
But they asked if I don't stream past chapter 6.
So...
It's a visual novel, so no gameplay.
No, no.
I think there's actually some taking care of...
The cafe, right?
Because we buy recipes and I think we have to make them...
I think we have to make them...
In the cafe.
There is gameplay.
Yeah, I thought so.
I thought so.
It's chapter 6.
Shiro gets the minky skin.
There is gameplay.
It's literally up next.
See?
I told you.
I think because we got that little sneak peek...
When we made...
Made...
When we did the cafe.
Ok.
Okidoki.
I'm gonna get going.
My throat hurts because...
I've been doing a lot of practicing for...
For the concert.
And I've had some other stuff that I've been recording.
Some stuff that is pretty cool.
That you will hear about later this month.
Maybe.
So, yeah.
I'm gonna go to...
Minto!
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, let's see.
Can we... Hold on.
Let me see if I can do this.
Oh, what the heck?
Do this.
Maybe if I subject you to this.
Let's see.
I can't.
Never mind.
I was gonna redirect to Doki.
I was gonna read Doki, but...
She doesn't have it turned on, so...
Never mind.
You can watch her if you want.
I was gonna subject you to Fortnite.
Oh well.
Anyway, manual read if you want.
If you want to go bother her.
Otsu Minto!
Itterasshaimase!
Everybody!
Bye bye!
Bye bye, have a good night!
Bye bye, bye bye, bye bye, bye bye!
Thanks for the stream!
See you!
Bye bye!
It just looks like the game again.
It just looks like we are in the game.
Right?
What
do you mean I'm not subscribed to Doki?
Because I am.
She doesn't have the raids turned on.
I'm literally subscribed to her.
She has to turn it on on her end.
It's not me.
Oh, she's a big liar.
That's what she said.
No, that would mean she's not subscribed to me.
What?
OK, I'm gonna go talk.
That means she's not subscribed to me!
Not the other way around.
OK, bye.